before I hit play I want to let you know
that this video sponsored by blue apron
I recently partnered with them on a
cooking video can't handle heat since we
filmed that video I become even a bigger
fan of blue apron and I've seen the very
positive comments you guys have left
down below in that video and are
enjoying the service too so I want to
extend their offer the first hundred
people who click the link in the
description box will get $50 off their
first two weeks of blue apron it's
healthy ingredients that are delivered
right to your door the recipes already
pre-planned for you so for someone like
me who's a novice chef and doesn't
really know how to cook it makes the
process a lot easier I always say the
most important thing is to be in charge
of your health and one of the major ways
to do that is to know what goes into
your body
[Music]
I was probably four years old when the
show came out so a lot has changed in
medical practice but I think it's gonna
be kind of cool to show how we've
evolved in our medical practices
[Applause]
the colors are accurate it looks like
this could have been filmed today I
think that probably has something to do
with the fact that hospitals haven't
been updated in decades in their
appearance me you ain't seen nothing yet
it's never a good idea to take the cap
off the syringe with your mouth because
what if it flicks off and then you end
up stabbing yourself in the face not a
good idea I get sometimes in a trauma
situation people do it
there's no rush to be had here so take
it off with your hands throw it in the
sharps bin make sure you don't stab
somebody and get a needle stick okay
never a fan of promising patients
results I understand in a trauma
situation you need to calm people down
because when you calm them down heart
rate drops and you have a better chance
of survival but I just wouldn't give
false promises I would say you know
we're taking great care of you we're
working on saving your hand the best
thing you can do for us right now is to
relax
[Music]
he just literally put one of the paddles
on the top of her chest and the other
one will look like on her like abdomen
to shock her it's not the way you do it
you have to do it on the chest area give
you something for the pain given Titus
and five of morphine right away
the reason why they say specifically
open fracture that means that your bone
has broken and has penetrated out of
your skin
so that's dangerous for two reasons
number one high chance of infection
because you have an open wound second
because sometimes the bone can put
pressure on your blood vessels and
therefore caused something known as
claudication which means that you're not
getting enough circulation so part of
the bone of a part of the body and then
that area can swell and it could be very
dangerous and you need emergent surgery
for that and then on top of it you could
obviously lose a lot a lot of blood
because you have an open fracture that
you need to get closed and reduced
to us come on I don't know where his
hands are in that scene just because
you're seeing the electrical activity
look good on the monitor you have to
feel for the pulse if you don't feel a
pulse that can just be pulseless
electrical activity it means that the
heart has rhythm but and the electricity
is there but the heart is not completely
beating properly to get the blood flow
going throughout your body patients
still cardiac arrest
it means you have to keep going with
your advanced cardiac life support
father had a heart attack I sort of get
what this patient's going through I mean
I've lost family members before but it's
also inappropriate to be physical with
any healthcare professional doctor nurse
PA anybody the one thing that Zee dog
does a really good job on you could
check out his channel he also makes
really good medical videos he stands up
for health care worker abuse and we
really need to put more attention to
that because it's contributing to
doctors burning out nurses burning out
increasing rates of suicide in the
health care profession field because
while this patient lost his one father
and he's acting this way it's
understandable but this doctor is gonna
see 2030 patients like this and if they
all do this you're not gonna last a very
long time practicing especially if
you're working five six days a week
oh paper charts I haven't touched the
paper chart ages we worked 36 hours on
18 off which is 90 hours a week 52 weeks
EF event we have paid twenty three
thousand seven hundred thirty-nine
dollars before taxes and we also have to
make the coffee my heart is breaking
residents nowadays make somewhere in the
range of I would say forty to sixty five
thousand depending where your program is
what kind of program it is now there's
our restrictions in place we're interns
especially can only work 16-hour shifts
at a time you have to have certain
amount of hours in between your shifts
there's weekly caps as I mentioned in my
Gray's Anatomy review
the libby's ion law in new york state
started this trend of instituting hourly
caps on residence and it spread to all
50 states at this point we still have
pagers and sometimes you can send the
messages to your phones but the reason
why that we're trying to reduce the
amount of pages overhead is to allow
patients to rest and sleep if you think
about it who's in the hospital sick
people people who need to get better how
do they get better through rest because
body heals itself if you constantly have
pages going on overhead it's very
difficult for a patient to sleep oh no
would you look at this that's the first
Taylor Blake code I've ever seen this is
really funny so Noah Wyle this actor
people tell me all the time how much I
remind them of him I probably get that
more than I get the whole McDreamy think
you know the McDreamy things are running
jokes but people say it looks so much
like him this first comment that I see
of them as them making fun of the fact
that he has a tailored white coat and I
actually have a white coat that's very
fitted and my nurses and my colleagues
always make fun of me like oh look at
dr. Mike with his fancy white coat I
just I just think it's important to look
professional or clean and you know
suited up as a doctor you know you work
hard you want to preserve this image of
professionalism so I don't think it's a
bad thing and I know they're gonna pick
on him cuz I experienced people picking
on me about it an angiocath with a 16
needle you need a large bore in case
they're bleeding and you need to
transfuse them do you know how to start
an IV uh actually no I thought you were
third-year I am but all I've done is
dermatology in psychiatry as a medical
student in your first two years you're
pretty much in the classroom and just
learning the curriculum everything you
need to know about the human body in
your third year you start doing your
clinical rotations especially your
course family medicine internal medicine
surgery it's not unusual for a third
year to come in and not know how to do
an IV and generally they're trained by
either senior students or young
residents or interns it's scary being on
your rotation for the
the way that I came about it and I had
some success was that I came very very
excited to learn and I wanted to learn
how to do IVs I wanted to learn how to
do procedures and anything that somebody
would let me do or let me watch or let
me practice I would be the first to
volunteer I wouldn't try and steal
opportunities from other people because
I don't want to be a gunner and a gunner
is a person who tries to put other
people down and get themselves ahead at
all costs even if it hurts someone else
wasn't one of those people but I was
very motivated and if you're a medical
student you want to shine on rotations
be motivated okay man we're gonna push
on the next one okay one two three the
best way to deliver a baby is during
their contractions you should tell the
patient to push and you wanted them to
hold the pressure for the push as much
as possible and then if there's time
they can exhale gather their strength
and push again while the contractions
going on pushing while the contraction
is not going on is not ideal because the
uterus is not contracting the baby out
therefore you're not gonna have any real
success in getting the baby out
and it's not a newborn baby there's a
very large baby you could tell so now
what we do in the hospitals is if the
baby's crying and the baby's breathing
the first thing we do is right away put
the baby on the moms breast that has
shown the best results bonding with the
baby is very important it comes the
mother down it comes the baby down it's
one of the things that we're really
pushing in all the major hospital
systems Titus Media is a very common ear
infection in young children it's when
the middle ear becomes infected with
usually a bacterial infection you do
need antibiotics for it because it can
actually spread to the local tissues to
the bone there's a part of the of the
skull called the mastoid process and you
can get masted itis there it could be
very dangerous especially when a baby's
so young and fragile especially in the
early days of life everyone has a family
mock my wife launched a shop kids grow
up you want a private school college you
got to think about that now the office
for our next associate is here the
constant dilemma for ER physicians is
that you often work very long hours the
hours that you do work are very
stressful you're seeing a lot of
patients there's a high stress rate in
this type of job because you never know
what kind of patients you're gonna get
what those doctors essentially offering
dr. Greene is to leave the ER work as an
outpatient physician where he would have
a little bit more flexibility a little
less stress better lifestyle but he's
not practicing the type of medicine he
seems to want to practice and he dreamed
of practicing so it's always a decision
that I see my colleagues struggle with
that do they want the intense excitement
of working in an ER setting or do they
want something more suitable to their
lifestyle that they can start a family
the attentive to their family have a
more set schedule with weekends off if
you are really passionate about a
specific field of medicine
you can't imagine doing anything else so
I can totally see dr. Greene saying no
to this and saying I would prefer to
work in the stressful
er because that's where his passion lies
are you afraid to tell me the truth
your history of coughing blood weight
loss and this x-ray is suggestive of
cancer but the diagnosis has not been
confirmed and it may very well be
something else and none of us should
jump to any conclusions until we know
that's what I think
I want to I am
six months to a year no doctor could
look at an x-ray and from the x-ray just
make a guess of how long a patient has
from life expectancy standpoint without
a biopsy bronchoscopy without a cat scan
even what she was doing in the first
place was correct you have to tell them
that what you suspected to be give your
differential explain the next step in
treatment but not to give him a life
expectancy that's wrong it's gonna be
inaccurate you told me how long has it
been since you've had your last period
I don't know I just think back
tell me roughly it was after Christmas
okay so it's been a few months I guess
so I haven't really pay attention and
you've had sexual intercourse
yes dr. Carter what you have is an
ectopic pregnancy she needs to be
scheduled for an ultrasound and surgery
right now he asked her when her last
period was she says she wasn't sure
maybe a few months ago he asked if she
had sexual intercourse she said yes
and he just makes a diagnosis of an
ectopic pregnancy without doing a
physical exam this is just this is so
inaccurate you may suspect the neck
topic pregnancy from doing a physical
exam and getting a full history but you
don't diagnose someone with that that's
just it's wild she could have so many
other things she could have because it's
left lower sided abdominal pain it could
be something with her stool she could
have a lot of gas
she could have dairy take your lightest
obviously not so common in her age group
even sometimes appendicitis which
normally happens on the right side can
present with lower left-sided abdominal
pain she could also have a cyst in her
ovary that could be causing discomfort
so to just say that she has an ectopic
pregnancy from that oh my god that's so
wrong the people sitting around for huh
the arterial got a Babinski yeah so a
Babinski reflex is when you stroke the
bottom of the sole of the foot with a
sharp object and not a very sharp object
with like a pointy object like the back
of a reflex hammer and if you stroke
upwards the toes in an adult are
supposed to flex downwards as if they're
grabbing the object if they extend away
and the big toe goes up that's actually
a sign of central nervous system damage
and in times of an overdose that could
be a very bad predictive sign oh he fell
out of his crib but he's been crying
when to defer whatever was so a young
child with multiple bruising multiple
contusions is very suspicious for child
abuse and it would need to be screened
by children Family Services
another thing that it makes us
suspicious about child abuse is
fractures and in different stages of
healing also a child that is scared to
talking from their parents
could be an early sign speak in front of
their parents could be an early sign
because they're hiding how they got
their injuries are lying to you to try
and cover up for their family a very
unfortunate common death in children
especially young infants like six months
of age 3 months of age is shaken baby
syndrome where after crying for a very
long period of time frustrated parents
will shake their baby very hard to get
them to stop and actually cause severe
spinal or and/or brain damage which
causes the baby to stop breathing and
die it's horrible when this happens I've
seen this happen so that's why I always
screen my parents that my parents my
parents my patients who are parents to
find out how they're doing in raising
their child if there's any symptoms of
depression if they're overly stressed
out because then I try and get them help
and give them some stress management
techniques and really tell them what to
do in case that they're feeling these
emotions creep in so they don't make a
horrible
like that was standing blocking traffic
but he's got that smell so I thought I'd
check you did the right thing diabetic
ketoacidosis let's go
very commonly folks who are in diabetic
ketoacidosis which means that their
blood sugar is so high
their blood is becoming acidotic and all
the functions all the cellular processes
that go on in your body start collapsing
and breaking down and you can die from
diabetic ketoacidosis and what this
police officer saying is you got that
smell on him is because you have a very
fruity aroma when you're going through
diabetic ketoacidosis it's a very
distinct smell if you smelled it before
you know exactly what the police officer
is talking about that feeling when you
go to sleep and you know you have a
couple hours to nap when you're on call
oh my god those are the most precious
hours cuz your eyes are just closing
you're just exhausted but it feels so
good even like thirty minutes of sleep
it's really important to prevent you
from going crazy 6:30 dr. Greene and it
really does feel like that you slept ten
seconds it's been two hours
ER is a classic it's well written it's
well produced I really could see myself
binge watching this show I mean I
watched this show when I was like eight
nine years old but now being a doctor
it's cool watching this and learning how
they did certain things back in the 90s
what problems they had so if you want to
binge this show it's actually available
on Hulu right now like I always say if
you have any recommendations or you have
some questions jump into the comment
section cuz you know I respond if not
down there in my monthly responding to
comments video as always stay happy and
healthy
[Music]